I've been requested to do a ladder
rate-of-change problem and I figure I
would do one because it really is the
classic rate-of-change problem so and
it's part of any complete calculus
education so what is the ladder rate of
change problem so let's say I have the
ground and I will do the ground in brown
let me see where I'm going to draw my
wall see this is the ground that's too
thin see this is the ground thicker
ground that's the ground and then I have
a red wall Reds a little yellow wall
this is my yellow wall and then leaning
against that yellow wall and the ground
I have a ladder I have a ladder so this
is the ladder I'm looking at it from the
side that's my ladder I'm just going its
side view either this is wall this is a
ground that's a ladder leaning against
the wall
and let's say that my ladder is 10
meters long 10 meters long so and and
and let's say that for whatever reason
I've kind of greased up this this this
wall and this and the floor here and so
you know a normal ladder would just kind
of you know stay where it is but
especially because this floor is all
greased up the bottom of this ladder is
moving to the left let me draw that let
me draw an arrow so the bottom of this
ladder is moving to the left and let's
say it's moving to the left at 4 meters
per second 4 meters per second so let's
think about a couple things what's
happening and let's when when this when
this point right here is moving to the
left at 4 meters per second as long as
we have some height here you know at
some point this whole thing is going to
fall down the drag the the ladder for
whatever arbitrary reason will just be
you know it'll just be sliding along the
ground maybe you know someone's pulling
it or whatever but before the ladder
completely falls to the ground while
this is being pulled out this way this
point right here is going to be coming
down right think about is just going to
be in fact that's probably what's
causing it to to slide to the left and
actually it'll do it an accelerating
rate
we're not going to worry all about that
we're just going to do the classic
ladder problem but I just want to give
you the intuition that if you were to I
don't know if you were to put a roller
here and put a roller there that that's
what a ladder would do it would slide
down and when it slides down this point
would go to the base of the floor right
here right this point would go down and
this point would go out to the left
until the ladder is into you know until
the ladder is like in something like
this position until it is flat on the
ground I'm just doing it right below the
line right and at that point it would
neither stop but if someone's pulling it
then it could continue to go at 4 meters
per second whatever so hopefully you're
satisfied that with that so my question
to you is at what is the rate of change
of this point of the kind of top of the
ladder what it's what is its rate of
change downwards when the left point of
the ladder right here is going to the
left at 4 meters per second and this
distance right here let me see this does
let me do it in a different color this
distance right here is 8 meters actually
let me let me do the whole let me do the
mirror image of that just because I
don't want to use negative numbers and
all of that I just realized today so let
me just draw it really messy real quick
on this side so that's the ground that's
the wall I'll do the ladder in a
different color still that's the ladder
it's 10 meters this point right here is
moving to the right at 4 meters per
second because I actually I'm going to
do the the horizontal component as X and
I wanted this to be a positive x value
instead of a negative x value so that's
why I did that we're eight meters away
so it's positive x right if we take this
zero zero and what I want to figure out
is the rate of change of this point of
the ladder at the top point of the
ladder did that how fast is that moving
down right so how do we think about this
well let's call this distance right here
let's call that distance X because it is
it's kind of the horizontal displacement
and let's call this distance up here Y
right so at any given point in time
how does X Y and 10 relate well this is
a right angle so we can use the
Pythagorean theorem
so we know that x squared plus y squared
is equal to what it's equal to the
hypotenuse squared is equal to ten
squared which is equal to 100 so this
right here describes you know if you
watch the video on on implicit functions
or implicit differentiation this is kind
of an implicit function of x and y right
or an implicit function of X really so
what can we do now well we're dealing
with rates of change with respect to
time right this is for meters per second
this is the rate of change or this for
meters per second this is the rate of
change at which X is changing with
respect to time right that's DX DT how
much does X move in a very small amount
of time and what are we looking for
we're looking for how fast is this Y
this Y value moving downward right so
we're looking for dy DT that's what
we're that's essentially what the
question is asking for how fast is Y
changing is a function of time when X is
changing at a function of time at 4
meters per second and X the value of X
is equal to 8 meters so I know that
seems very complicated but essentially
all we do is we take the derivative of
both sides of this equation with respect
to time so let's do that so let's take
the derivative with respect to time of x
squared plus y squared equals and we
have to do it both sides of this
equation
100 so what's the derivative with
respect to time of x squared well it's
the chain rule it's the derivative with
respect to X of this entire expression
so that's 2x times the derivative of X
with respect to time that's just the
chain rule plus the derivative of this
expression with respect to Y so it's 2y
times the derivative of Y with respect
to time and if you found this to be a
little confusing you might want to watch
the video that actually just did on
implicit differentiation it gives a
little bit more intuition why this
really just is the chain rule
but hopefully it you get this up in a
little bit and then how much does 100
change with respect to time well this
100 value is never going to change
because frankly the length of the ladder
is never going to change right that's
where that hundred comes from is ten
squared so the rate of hundred with
respect to time well it never changes so
it's equal to zero and what do we what
do we know we know X right we know X is
what X is at this point in time is 8
meters we know the change of X with
respect to time is 4 meters per second
do we know why well I think we do when X
is 8 what is y well we could just use
this formula right here we have 8
squared plus y squared is equal to 100
so 64 plus y squared is equal to 100 or
Y squared is equal to 36 and we know you
know so Y is plus or minus 6 but we know
that we're only dealing with positive
values in this at least in this example
right here so Y is equal to 6 so we know
X we know the rate of change of X versus
time that was given in the problem four
meters per second we know Y so then we
can solve for the rate of change of Y
with respect to time so let's do that
let's just substitute the values so
what's X we're saying well what is the
rate of change of Y is the pec time when
X is 8 so we get 2 times 8 that's x
times the change in so this is 8 what's
the change in X with respect to time at
this moment in time it's 4 meters per
second that's 4 so 2 times 8 times 4
plus 2 times y we just figured out that
Y is 6 so this is 6 so 2 times plus 2
times 6 times and this is what we're
solving for dy DT is equal to 0 so what
is this 2 times 8 is 16 2 times 8 is 16
times 4 is 64 right so 64 plus 12 dy DT
and let me let me erase some stuff I
tend to try to crowd too much into one
window
making things confusing actually this is
she already drawn that so let me erase
my whoops I think that is good enough
okay so then we can simplify up here so
let's just sit
oh that equals zero subtract 64 from
both sides we get 12 dy DT is equal to
minus 64 and then you get the change in
Y with respect to time is equal to minus
64 over 12 and what's the greatest
common factor instead think it's a four
so that equals minus 16 over three right
and or that you could say that's you
know five and one third or five point
three is going to be meters per second
that's that's the units so the change
let me write it that way just so is
equal to you know minus five point three
three I mean you can put whatever meters
per second and there we have it and you
might say hey why is there that minus
there well it makes sense because while
the x-value it's rate of change with
respect to time it's going in the
positive direction right at least the
way I drew it here the X is going to the
right so it's it's its change is
positive but what's happening to the Y
value the Y value it's you could say
it's velocity right its velocity is
downward so that's where that negative
value comes from because it has a
negative velocity I mean really we're
just this is kind of just the X&Y
velocities of those of those different
points and you know it's you can think
about it a little bit that the X at
least at that point in time while the x
value is increasing at four meters per
second the Y value is is moving even
faster downwards so that's something to
think about but you might want to
experiment with it at different points
in time because it's going to be
dependent on on where we are you know
and then kind of at what what does the
right triangle look like but anyway that
is the classic rate of change problem
the latter problem I will see you in the
next video